from uh
alien scientist perspective if you were
to look
back on earth
is there something interesting you could
say about earth like how would you
summarize earth
like in a report you know like uh
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy
like if you had to report like write a
paper on earth
or like a letter like a like a one pager
um summarizing the contents of the
surface and the atmosphere is there is
there something interesting
like do you ever take that kind of
perspective on it
i know you like volcanism so volcanoes
that will probably be in the report
i was going to say that's where i was
going to go first there are a few things
to say about the atmosphere but in terms
of the volcano so
one of the really interesting puzzles
to me in planetary science is so we can
we can look out there and we've been
talking about
surfaces and volcanoes and atmospheres
and things like that
but that is just you know this tiny
little veneer on the outside of the
planet and most of the planet
is completely sort of inaccessible to
telescopes or to spacecraft missions you
can drill a meter into the surface but
you know that's still really the veneer
um and one of the cool puzzles is
looking at what's going on
on the surface and trying to figure out
what's happening underneath or just
any kind of indirect means that you have
to study the interior because you can't
dig into it directly even on earth you
can't dig deep into earth
so from that perspective looking at
earth
one thing that you would be able to tell
from orbit given enough
time is that earth has tectonic plates
so you would see that volcanoes follow
the edges
if you trace where all the volcanoes are
on earth they follow these
lines that trace the edges of the plates
and similarly you would see
things like the uh hawaiian string of
volcanoes
that you could infer just like you know
we did
as people actually living on earth that
the plates are moving over some plume
that's coming up through the mantle
and so you could use that to say if the
aliens could look at where the volcanoes
are
are happening on earth and say something
about the fact that earth has plate
tectonics which makes it really
unique in the solar system okay so the
other plants don't have
it's the only one that has plate
tectonics yeah what about io and the the
friction and all that that's not plate
what's the difference between so oh it's
plate tectonics like another layer
of like solid rock that moves around and
there's cracks
yeah so so earth has plates of solid
rock
sitting on top of a partially molten
layer and those plates are kind of
shifting around on io
it doesn't have that and the volcanism
is what we call heat pipe volcanism
it's the magma just punches a hole
through the crust and comes out on the
surface i mean that's a simplification
but that's effectively what's happening
through the freezing cold crust yes
very cold very rigid crust yeah how do
you
how does that look like by the way i
don't think we've mentioned
so the gas that's expelled like if we
were to look at it is it look beautiful
does it look boring
the gas like the whole thing like the
the magma punching through
oh my gosh the icy yes i'm sure it would
be beautiful and the pictures we've seen
of it are beautiful you have
so the the magma will come out of the
lava will come out of these fissures
and you have these curtains of lava that
are
maybe even a kilometer high so if you
looked at videos
i don't know how many volcano videos
you've looked at on earth but you
sometimes see a tiny tiny version of
this in iceland you see just
these sheets of magma coming out of a
fissure when you have this really low
viscosity magma sort of water-like
coming out at these sheets
and the plumes that come out because
there's no atmosphere
all the plume molecules are just our
plume particles
where they end up is is just a function
of the
direction that they left the vent so
they're all following ballistic
trajectories
um and you end up with these umbrella
plumes you don't get these sort of
complicated plumes that you have on
earth
that are occurring because of how that
material is interacting with the
atmosphere that's there
you just have these huge umbrellas and
it's been hypothesized actually that
the atmosphere is made of sulfur dioxide
and
that you could have these kind of ash
particles from the volcano and the
sulfur dioxide
would condense onto these particles and
you have sulfur dioxide snow coming out
of these volcanic plumes
and uh there's not much light though
right
so you wouldn't be able to like it would
make a good it would not make a good
instagram photo because you have to
would you see the snow sure there's
light
it depends okay so you could you could
okay depends what angle you're looking
at it where the sun is all the things
like that you know the sunlight is much
weaker but it's still there it's still
there
and uh how big is i o in terms of
gravity is it smaller is it a pretty
small moon
it's quite a bit smaller than earth
anyway it's smaller than earth okay
okay cool so they flood out for a little
bit so it floats wow
yeah no you're right that would be that
would be that would be gorgeous
um now what else about earth
is interesting besides volcanic so plate
tectonics i didn't realize that that was
the unique
element of a planet in the solar system
uh because that i wonder what
i mean we experience it as human beings
it's quite painful because of
earthquakes and all those kinds of
things but
i wonder if there's nice features to it
yeah so coming back to habitability
again
um things like tectonics and plate
tectonics are are thought to play an
important role
in the surface being habitable and
that's because you have a way of
recycling material
so if you have a stagnant surface
everything
you know you use up all the free oxygen
everything reacts until you no longer
have
reactants that life can extract energy
from
and so if nothing's changing on your
surface you kind of reach this
stagnation point
but something like plate tectonics
recycles material you bring up new fresh
material from the interior you bring
down
material that's up on the surface and
and that can
kind of refresh your your nutrient
supply in a sense or
the sort of raw materials that the
surface has to work with
so um from a kind of astrobiologist
perspective looking at earth you would
see
that recycling of material because the
plate tectonics you would also see how
much oxygen
is in earth's atmosphere and between
those two things you would identify
earth as a
reasonable candidate for a habitable
environment
in addition to of course the you know
pleasant temperature and liquid water
but the abundance of oxygen and the the
plate tectonics both
play a role as well
you